and let me introduce stefan Hoyer who
will be talking about x-ray extended
arrays for scientific data sets and he
is a quantitative researcher at the
climate corporation located in San
Francisco where he built statistical
models for whether the weather climate
for agronomic applications and he
recently graduated from Berkeley so
let's welcome in hi my name is again as
seven where I'm going to tell you about
an open source project that we started
recently for working with labeled
multi-dimensional arrays in Python and
the slides from my talk I just tweeted
them with a PI data hashtag so if you're
curious you can follow along or see the
the notebook so I wanted to really
briefly introduce the client corporation
that's where I work so I'm a scientist I
work mostly a team that deals with
weather data but what the company does
is provides data driven advice to to
farmers in our culture helpful make
decisions like when should they plant
how much fertilizer should they put on
sort of day-to-day decisions that they
can we can sort of use a lot of a lot of
data and a lot of agronomic modeling and
sort of weather modeling to give them to
give them advice about how they can
improve their operations so we're going
a lot of data and i want to show some
the data set to work with so that's all
the motivation in part for this project
so we work with a radar data set which
is like weather radar for measuring
rainfall over the whole United States
this is a data set from the produce by
tiling together a bunch of radar
stations by the National Weather Service
we look at gauge data which is sort of
more sparsely structured but it's like a
like a rain gauge in somebody's backyard
or not backyard but at a weather station
and then we deal with data that comes
from numerical weather forecasts so
these are sort of systems that are run
on giant super computers or the
basically the bulk oh
the many of the world's biggest super
computers are used to make weather
forecasts and to run these like weather
simulations so we make use these or a
data sets and they produce a lot of data
and they're very very rich data and then
we also work with with satellite images
which can give you a sense of like
exactly what if so to use so we can
actually see fields and see how well
they're growing from like from space or
also like from say from airplanes you
can give a lot of information that way
all right so we so I am a big fan of
Python and a particular I guess I don't
you tell you is this but the pandas
library is really awesome for working
with data and Python it happen takes
care of a lot of things that make it
real life a lot easier as a scientist
doing data analysis and particularly
things like how it handles missing data
how it sort of automatically aligns data
you can keep track of labels and a few
other things like like wait like time
series or the group by operations are
really handy and of course the biggest
thing is that it interrupts
interoperates pretty nicely now with
sort of the sort of family of other
libraries or so from the PI data
ecosystem and pandas works with them so
it's kind of becoming like a service
standard type for working with labeled
data which is awesome now here are some
of the data we work with so these are a
data set that's five dimensional weather
forecasts so you have sort of a couple
of traditional dimensions so this with
like it like a latitudinal 12 dimension
and then you have a time dimension also
you're forecasting for different days
and then with weather data you run the
as soon as you run though you make a
weather forecast you start your
supercomputer up again and start making
a new weather forecast because if new
data and you want to predict you know
make a new prediction so that's another
time dimension and then they're actually
probability forecasts so you try to
understand the somatic uncertainty in
the weather so they run a model bunch of
times and parallel as well and that
gives you that gives you a sort of
weather scenario axis so I have a five
dimensional array of data and it's all
labeled data which is nice that's sort
of what what we would hope that
something like like pandas would excel
at it's pretty big data I mean in many
cases we can subset the data but I mean
but largely it comes they're really
hundreds of gigabytes or more of this
data and it's also of course it's sort
of commits a store in these very
compressed like binary formats and it's
a high-dimensional so it's not
immediately clear how to put it into an
object to panic and handle like a data
frame so I wanted to sort of show you so
the options we thought these are went
through so first of all Panetta's is
this object called a n-dimensional panel
you you may or may not have seen this
but it's well partly cuz it's a little
awkward to use you have to make you
basically this is straight from the
pandas docs actually and the way that
you make an n-dimensional panel is you
you make your own factory to make
n-dimensional panels and you sort of
supply all of these all these these you
supply a lot of like sort of label based
information and then some other things
like a statistical axis that like so
it's a pretty awkward setup and it also
doesn't at least in the current
implementation in pandas it's not very
good for doing math you can only add a
scalar value to an dimensional panel and
it's not really it's not quite through
the structure we're looking at look we'd
like to have molded mental raised so the
other the other option would be to put
things in a sort of a more sort of a
one-dimensional object this looks more
like a tabular data set like what you
would expect like sort of what panas is
I think it's a little this is really
well designed for and so you can make it
like a series and you can sort of label
at your observations and it is a nice
way of sending data but it's not
fundamentally multi-dimensional so it
doesn't it so you said you sort of lose
some nice aspects of being we'd like to
be able to work with really n
dimensional arrays so that's so alright
so what we want so we're looking for a
data structure that is a like a numpy
multi-dimensional array but they can
also make use
of metadata and that is right so sort of
like pandas but for really n dimensional
so especially like features like how
pandal pandas handles missing data how
it handles and how it hand soap anna's
also labels as data that one one
significant difference is that we
between what you can do in pandas and
what we would like is we would like to
be able to label the dimensions with
names so i can say i have a time axis or
like a latitude axis and pandas you have
always have an index or columns or you
can give like numerical accys numbers
that's what you can do into an empire
also that's not but ideally we'd sort of
put all that information in there and
that would let us make more powerful
tools that can make you that can
automatically be aware of the metadata
and another feature which is not a
little tan gentle to these other aspects
is we want something that can work okay
for handling data sets that are too big
to fit into memory sort of at least so
sort of going towards working with big
data very least I should be able to load
a file from disk sub and or rather open
a file on my disk this may be many
gigabytes and say I want to select out a
particular subset of that file to work
with without having to load the entire
the entire file on disk in the memory
which is probably impossible ok so this
that's sort of the context for this new
project x-ray which is and police say we
released the first version of it
yesterday it's an open source on github
and so we want right these labeled n
dimensional arrays and the other the
sort of the major goal is we wanted to
sort of leverage sort of all this
knowledge we have about how to work with
these server rays and all these tools
that already exist so especially pandas
so we reuse the pandas as an index
object which makes it which works really
well for I guess if you want to label
tick marks along along a particular axis
of a dimension and so we reuse that that
object from pandas and we also try to
copy the API from hand
and of course we want to interoperate
smoothly with the rest of sort of the
scientific Python community in PI data
so we want to be able to sort of send
our objects turn them into something
that like a native Pandits object or
sort of convert them back the other way
and the other aspect is that we wanted
to build a build around a data model
that we've seen it's been very
successful in the geosciences and this
is the netcdf file format and so i'll
get kind of get into what that that
means in a little bit but it's a very
nice way for for working with lip with
labeled multi-dimensional arrays so I
really wanted to mention there are a few
other projects that made attempts to or
that have done sort of labeled labeled
array data in Python there is a data
array project which sort of never really
got beyond a prototype stage there's
there's another library Larry which is
not which is sort of not fully
self-described data doesn't have label
dimensions and sort of similar things to
what Pandits doesn't some sense a little
bit different but still not quite what
we want there's this library from the UK
Meteorological Office iris which is
which is very good if you have like
extremely sort of well labeled data
that's like for like like earth science
specific if you have if you like all the
units are labeled and you are very
careful about maintain your meta down
the railway it works great but otherwise
it's not and then of course there
there's also continuum has the blaze
which I'm optimistic will eventually
have the will will be able to
interoperate with or will have good
support for labeled arrays as well okay
so before I get into show you a demo I
wanted to briefly briefly describe the
data model that we use so there's a sort
of two first-class their two main
objects in the public API for x-ray and
the one object is a data array object
which is a it's the labeled
multi-dimensional array that I described
earlier in the main so distinguishing
features are that it has label
dimensions so you can again so you can
aggregate on with the time dimension and
it has a homogeneous data type so it's
not you can if you
make an array of type float it's only
floats there's no like different columns
I different data types you shouldn't you
can make a separate array if you have
different data types and then there's
another object to contain these these
arrays called a data set and the data
set is a dictionary like container of
the arrays and it keeps track of shared
dimensions and coordinates so that you
can share a dimension like the time axis
between different arrays and that turns
out to be very handy and then we also
can keep track of the other thing we add
is the ability to keep track of any
extra metadata you want in the form of a
dictionary which is called an attribute
in the in the parlance of the netcdf or
like the hdf5 file formats okay so now
for the demo they make this readable
here and just second great all right
I'll be brave and do a my life down was
this is this big enough to read in the
back yes okay great so again we are on
sir this is all you can download this
online later if you like I tweeted the
link alright so Ron 0.1 of this library
which we just released so the main so
this were the main way you get data into
x ray is to make it these data set
objects and essentially the the one up
at one aspect that again that you're
required to do is to label your
dimensions so when you pass objects into
a data set you pass in sort of the
simplest way to make something is to
pass in tuples of that passing a
dictionary of tuples which label the
dimensions and then give the array
values so here I passed in a couple I
passed it at a time to mention in my
time variable and a foo variable and i
get back i see that i have a data set
object and i'll end a few more variables
here which has a collection of arrays so
the array the the the different so the
coordinates here are the equivalent
correspond to the dimension names and
the and the the non coordinates are the
other variables that are in my data set
so i have a few a couple of labeled
objects in here and again the data set
is a dictionary like object so i can do
all the dictionary methods to verify
that i have a that i have an array foo
in my data set i can look at the keys my
data set it's just all the it's all
these arrays that are listed on the left
and i can look at one of the values and
so I see that the time the the time
array is a it's this data object and it
consists of the main basically there's a
there's an umpire ray in there which a
numpad 8 x 64 array and then it has also
this it's called time and exists along
the time the time dimension that's how
you you you specify something is
existing along coordinate is you give it
the dimension its dimension is equal to
its name and that's that's how you say
that's how I want to label things along
the time-dimension I have another
variable here so here it actually it
created space variable for me as my
coordinate cuz I gave something with a
dimension of space but never actually
specified what this the space array was
that's similar to pandas without handles
indices and there's my data so it's a
two-by-four like a ray of some random
numbers okay and again I have all the
the dictionary stuff you would expect so
I can store the attributes or just an
order dictionary or I can put in some
extra metadata here and it adds i'll add
in some ads in some metadata which is
like saved along with you Ray so this is
a sort of handy way to like say save
information about the provenance of data
and in a self-contained way okay so now
the the data array object so again these
are sort of the items inside a data set
and they have these label dimensions and
labeled coordinates Harold's get that
take that object out it's like a pan
adopting the sense that it's a
wraparound an umpire a you can just do
the name of my array dot values and that
gives you out an umpire ray with all the
values inside inside this data array and
they also have these dimension labels
which is at uppal of a couple of strings
and this describe sort of gives you the
the sort of combination of these two
sort of give you describe specify I
guess how they have the array interprets
different operations and they can also
keep track of their own attributes so
indexing these arrays works mostly just
like it does in a numpy you can act an
essential for most of simple cases so i
can access say like the first element
along certain dimension is it acts as a
slice I can do you can use an array of
labels to index along one of my
dimensions and this is just just by
energy-based indexing and because we
have the the labels the labels along
each dimension I can also do I can also
do location-based indexing and here i
copied the syntax from from pandas where
you if you do array dot loke that gives
you it says i want to do location-based
indexing and you can see that you can
put in a string again this bar on the
machinery from pandas for a date and it
sort of automatically can convert that
into the right place to look up values
in the array so the other sort of nice
thing about because we have labeled the
dimensions is I don't need to to just
specify the let the order of the of the
dimensions in the erase best tell me how
I'm apply i'm going to index it but i
can also give them by name explicitly so
i can say i want to index it by the
space dimension certain item and then
the time dimension with wheezing a
function and i can also do that with the
labels as well and so are the next thing
about that that actually extends to
working with data sets as well so i can
index all the arrays in a data set to
grab at a particular value here i made
them all sort of size one but it's tells
the same
same items or I can take a particular
label like say grab everything from from
this particular date and you see every
every array in the data set was sliced
out based off of based off the label and
i'm left with for example a scalar time
dimension which is the one time value
that's left by applying that that's
slicing you can also put these cancers
stack these together using using the
metadata say I want to stack them along
a this new dimension label that's kind
of like it expects you can do the same
thing for stacking you can stack both
the arrays and you can stack the data
set with a concatenate methods you can
also merge in another another data set
into a dep and existing data set and
that will sort of automatically check
for for conflicts so that you can you
don't remove any data now the part that
I'm really excited about is how the data
array it works for for math and we can
do with that so the the basics of the
mathematical operations work just like
like I do an umpire pandas you can you
can add or subtract scalars or numpy
arrays you can actually use numpy
universal functions and get back another
data array like I here i am using num
pies sine function and you can also have
some methods like transpose for example
to switch dimensions and there are a few
other a few other examples of numpy like
methods that we've we've copied here so
for I guess actual example is it we've
added labels to operations like some so
I can sum on the time axis just by doing
datsun and then putting time or I can
give a like a list of different
dimensions to aggregate over and then ah
ok so then so then when you're doing
mathematical operations so one thing
that so I'll show you is we so numpy has
support for broadcasting which is which
lets you a do say add two arrays even if
they don't have the same dimensions or
the same the same length along each
dimension you can still add them
together so we do we can do something
like broadcasting but it's actually more
powerful with the labels so so let me
show you two
one-dimensional arrays one has three
items when is for items and now i'm
going to multiply them together and this
would not work and it would not work in
them pie but because i have the labels i
no one is among the time axis and one of
those is on the space axis I know
actually they're entirely orthogonal so
I can automatically broadcast them
against each other and I don't actually
have to worry about like adding in like
a dummy dimension of length one to make
the the the mathematical operations work
and you can even automatically reorder
the dimensions so that so they agree
because I'm their label so i can
subtract this array from its transpose
and it's you know and it works because
even though one objects which the space
and time dimensions one day when you add
them you should automatically
rationalize it automatically line them
up that's very convenient and we can
also do we can also do alignment on so
aligning dimensions you can also align
on a coordinate event value so this is
like what you can do in pandas but now
it works observe it in using the same
machinery from pandas actually but it
works multiple dimensions so i just made
another another another array that has
similar based on scaling the values in
the first array and so there's a there's
some a few methods one is a reindex like
which is again just copied from pandas
so i can say i want to take my food
variable and i want to put it on only
the but only the locations where i have
values in bar and it selects them out so
it does does all the right slicing and i
can also go the other way and if you go
the other way it will fill everything in
automatically with missing values with
not a number so you can see you can
automatically so you can align vary
based on these labels you can take care
of all the aligning all of your your
race and you can also do this there's a
we also a function which lets you do
like take combine two arbitrary objects
and and do and say doing an inner join
or an outer join again it's very similar
to this reindex like command but they
take the intersection of all the
dementia
labels and and both of these work
interchangeably with both the these
arrays and with the data set object so
the dads that objects can also be
indexed because they have these
dimension labels all right so of course
like i said before we really want to
interoperate with with pandas and the
whole and sort of the whole pie data
ecosystem so there's a very nice mapping
between these data set and data array
objects and the native objects in pandas
so the pandas dataframe the pandas
series the way we do that again to
remind you we have this this data set
here is we're going to take each of the
variables in the data set each the ones
and we're going to make them a column
the data frame so it flows together we
see that I end up with this pandas
dataframe where I have a hierarchical
index here it's a called a multi index
in pandas and it's the sort of the
tensor product of the of the of the of
the coordinates that I had along each of
my dimensions and then I have flattened
out each of these each of the arrays
into one dimensional object so you each
of these these like three different
arrays that I had in my data set is now
a column in the data frame and so now I
could pass this off to any number of of
libraries day to do visualization there
or I could pass or sort of or pass it
off the pan Dostum to use Italy any of
the pandas data handling tools directly
and then of course you can get you can
get these objects back to you can take
if I have a data frame that's in this in
the format where I have where each
column corresponds to a variable and I
have a multi index than to which I want
which then we can do this this off
opposite operation and you get back a
data set so the only sort of caveat here
is notice that we we had we the nya my
variables have more dimensions that they
had they had before and that's because
it's get them in the one dimensional
data frame form and i had to duplicate a
lot of the entries whereas if you have
the multi-dimensional the
multi-dimensional data set can handle
the doesn't need to do as much
locating the data and so the same way we
we can convert things into these pandas
series objects if you want to take a
single array you turn it into a painted
series which is a one dimensional object
again with labels and essentially this
thing at the same mechanism and you can
also go in reverse from a panda serious
get back with the data array so one
thing we were able to do is again in an
effort to copy everything from pandas we
make it work with multi-dimensional
arrays is a copy group by operations so
I have an array here with a couple of
items just two different standards laid
twice and then you can see 20 repeated
twice so i can make make this group by
object here on my data set and it's just
and then I if I iterate over it I get
back pairs of the of the labels and then
everything that what that is selected by
by that label so i can see that i select
out the first half my data set and then
the second half my data set court on
lawns dimension and the and i can do
that for both the assets and for the
data array objects and then the really
nice thing about this is you cannot is
the group by operation lets you do the
this this there's this split apply
combine paradigm for working with data
where you can express things like group
by these numbers this nut which in this
case is it an array in this data set and
then take the mean and it automatically
takes care of that for you so instead of
having to write your own loop to like
loop over to loop over every element
that matches the group and that name can
caddy me back together it's like this is
sort of this does it all together and
it's a really nice feature of pandas
that we copied and you can also apply
apply functions to different subsets so
for example here i have a standardized
function which will take the which rules
center and and normalize the data and i
can apply that with a group by to my to
my entire array as well with this apply
method so that's the group by right now
it only works for one dimensional for a
one-dimensional group but you could
imagine it working you could imagine it
working in like in multi-dimensions
though it gets we get a little more
complicated so now I want to talk about
I want to talk about serialization so
the the native serialization format for
x-ray is the netcdf format so netcdf is
a fully described data format it's a lot
it's actually it's in it's very popular
in geosciences it's a lot like hdf5 you
may have heard of if you've worked with
sign of data HTF I very popular netcdf
is at the most netcdf version 4 which is
sort of the only version we should use
if you can if you can manage is actually
an hdf5 file just following certain
conventions and the main difference is
that netcdf insists that you have to add
dimension names to each of to each of
your race you can't have just an array
of values you have you have to you have
to label it fully so that's why we're
using netcdf and so you can export one
of these data sets to a netcdf object
and you can get it back from front
floating us on disk and one nice feature
of this is that you actually you get
back this data set object but you
haven't actually loaded everything to
memory it's still on disk and the razor
stolen disk so I want to show a demo
here will we will see if this works but
has to load some data for a remote
server so this is using a protocol
called opened app which is a way that
you can access netcdf like data sets
over HTTP so I'm going to open a
connection to a server at Columbia
University and you see it get back on a
data set here which has I don't know
probably several gigabytes of data it's
a this is a bunch of historical gridded
estimates of like weather variables like
temperature and precipitation in the
United States and it's got I mean you
can't even see the size of dimension
it's about a thousand by a thousand by
1400 1400 x 600 so really big obviously
you know medium sized data i'm not going
to download it even on facebook's very
fast internet very quickly so i have i'm
going to take a look at an array here
and when you have sort of more lesser
number of values on disk instead of
seeing the actual values i see just
tells me that I have you know like a
billion values
I can't actually count the decimal
points there so I can do things like
apply I'm going to subset the data here
and I slice it and I still get back
another of these data array objects and
here i took say every third element and
and now i'll take out evil even further
select down and say take the own like
the first time and i'm going to do a if
you look at the metadata here you notice
it says something about a missing value
so I'm rich I'm going to fill in these
missing values with not a number and and
because I accesses that values attribute
it it's or local it cash the the values
from this remote data set as an umpire a
locally on this object and now I can I
can plot it see this works excellent so
we have a nice picture of team in for
someday in the far distant in the
probably like nineteen seventy or
something over the United States that's
in degrees Celsius I think all right so
all right so I wanted to briefly mention
a few sort of things we're working on
that hopefully will be in version to the
library or 0.2 so we haven't yet turned
on you notice i mentioned the automatic
alignment for dimensions haven't yet
turned it on for a lining math but to
aligning a coordinate values so allein
if i have like a certain selection of
dates in one array in a certain
selection of days dates in another array
and that's because so panis makes it has
a choice for that where they they say
use all the indices and then to fill
everything in with missing values so you
end up you end up than array with a lot
of missing values which a pretty
reasonable choice for pandas especially
when you're working with low dimensional
data because the worst case scenario you
end up with with an object back that is
only twice the size or really the sum of
the sizes of the two arrays you put in
if you have multi dimensional objects
you can end up with a lot like you know
very large array is coming back on
missing values so that seems like
probably less useful so we may I'm
inclined to do to default to trying to
do like an inner join to avoid
issues right now we don't have a
constructor to make a data array
directly you have to make a data set
first and I think there might be if i'ma
figure out a nice nice way to do that I
would like to be able make data data
raised directly instead of taking from
pandas there's still a lot of features
from pandas that we'd like to copy
especially for handling like missing
values that we just haven't sort of
gotten around to dealing with yet but
think and sir one last big aspect would
be allowing us to incrementally write
these objects to disk so that I can
process an array and i can write out
like a chunky irate to to a file on disk
and then and do that repeatedly so i
don't have to put everything into memory
all right so i had a few a few thoughts
about sort of based on my experience
with x-ray for sort of the PI data
audience the first thing was that you
don't really need heterogeneous data
types in your race if you have the right
sort of containers so pandas have every
if you think maybe it's the indication
you shouldn't really think of a data
frame as being a two dimensional as
being a two dimensional array of values
maybe it's more useful think of it as a
container of one-dimensional arrays in
the same way that the x-ray data set is
a container of n dimensional arrays in
that sense you don't necessarily need
heterogeneous data types in your race
and so a sandwi based all this a lot of
the tricky computation on this the
pandas index object which turned out to
be a real pleasure to work with and sort
of did work very quickly and the last
last point is that out of core
computation will obviously be sort of
really impactful when when it sort of
linked up to all these libraries for
like scientific computing so that all
right that's it so I wanted to briefly
thank my few of my coworkers at Cana
corporation who have contributed to
x-ray or have tested it and you for
listening
yeah so so a few questions if I can so
one what's the status of out of court
right now or just depending on that
cydia or is that like still in the
weight it works yeah so we don't really
have good support for out of I mean
nothing for like a four out of core
computation and the we can load data
lazily from a netcdf file but we can't
write data Leslie yeah that's something
that I intend to do shortly are you
familiar I'm not actually don't mode of
motion I don't know much about this fish
Millie with with like numpy mem mapped
is that sufficient that's a good
question and I'm not entirely sure to be
honest I mean that gives you know like a
jump i like semantics over God's finer
data on disk yeah i think that the one
aspect that we would like is i mean we
would like to be able incremental a
right to to the two netcdf file actually
because then it's fully self-described
we could define our own sort of on disk
file format it's like numpy raise plus i
don't know maybe a json file metadata
but that seems less than ideal granted
second question if I can so why I don't
understand why all the data sets need to
well the label to raise need to live in
the same data set couldn't you register
when you do sort of cross or a
computations can just register based off
of some shared token in the dimensions
yes so they don't need to live the same
data set in fact yes I guess I show that
in this talk but but in it you
absolutely do not need to have your
raised in the same data set you can make
as long as the dimension names match up
and the coordinate values line up you
can use arrays from different assets
really the data set is just a way of
organizing it when I have if I have
information that's all along the same
dimensions then yes put it all in one
data set but in general and we have a
lot of code where we're like we like
make like multiple datasets than when we
will will combine and compare from
different data sets hey I was wondering
did you maybe win over this and I missed
it but does this cover sparse data uh
not know at this point although although
I would love to add you know support for
sparks that I think could fit very
easily into this okay and I'm assuming
that you're under
lying data structures is an NDA ray or
very similar to an NDA ray right for
each dimension yes in fact I'm basically
once you load once you load data from an
from disk or from wherever you're
getting it from it's stored internally
it's cached as an umpire array yes I
denson umpire right
what kind of computation would be
possible on on disk I assume you can
increment or add values to arrays that
are on disk can you do like linear
algebra on a disk what what are the what
what is your goal for that well I mean
my hope it right now is not to try i'm
not going to try to do very complicated
computations in here because that well
to do it like a lazy computation but i
do want it again like added like
incremental rights because that's sort
of essential to doing that ultimately it
would be wonderful to be able to say I
have you know one data sets on disk I'm
going to do a bunch of I don't know at
least apply in some number of like like
mathematical operations baby it's
relatively simple things like I'm going
to take like a mean or I'm going to like
aggregated in some you know in some
simple ways say to sub set it down maybe
more reasonable data set or like or
tweak in a few it then write it out to
disk that that seems probably feasible I
mean you're probably not going to do a
you know to run machine learning
algorithm with the array on you know on
disk in a lazy fashion but simple things
yes all right let's think Stefan